vamos a hacer algunos ejemplos sobre
problemas que necesitan escribirse con
expresiones básicas de álgebra así que
vamos a usar expresiones algebraicas
básicas para escribir estos problemas y
el primero dice así field recibió un
premio de equis pesos en un torneo de
póker el torneo le costó 100 pesos de
entrada cuáles fueron las ganancias
netas de field en el torneo
escribe tu respuesta con una expresión y
ojo lo que buscamos unas ganancias netas
eso quiere decir que vamos a aplicarnos
en cuanto ganó él después de quitarle lo
que él invirtió en su entrada y si
observas el ganar x pesos del torneo de
poker y aunque se va a ir con estos
equis pesos esta no es su ganancia neta
así que a estos le vamos a quitar lo que
a él le costó la entrada ya que le costó
100 pesos la entrada es justo lo que me
dicen aquí así que aunque él vaya a
recibir
pesos por haber ganado el 29 poker
realmente sus ganancias netas fueron de
x menos 100 pesos no sé supongamos que
él ganó unos 105 pesos de premio en el
torneo de poker bueno si recibió 105
pesos de premio en el torneo de poker
entonces ese va a llevar a su casa a
esos 105 pesos pero las ganancias netas
que obtuvo field van a ser 105 menos 100
pesos o dicho otra manera 5 pesos esas
son las ganancias totales si nosotros
nos fijamos en cuánto ganó y a eso le
quitamos cuánto le costó invertir para
obtener la ganancia final muy bien vamos
a comprobar la respuesta y vamos a hacer
el siguiente bien tengo ahora este sushi
participó en una carrera ocurrió a 5
millas por hora y tardó t horas en
completar la carrera de cuántas millas
era la carrera
escribe tu respuesta como una expresión
para obtener la cantidad de millas de
otra manera la distancia que susi
recorrió en esta carrera lo que vamos a
hacer es multiplicar a la velocidad que
es 5 y está dada en millas por hora y lo
vamos a multiplicar por las horas que
ella tardó en completar la carrera lo
cual sabemos que es t entonces 5 por t
ahora otra forma de escribirlo sería
poner simplemente 5 t 5 t 25 punto t es
exactamente lo mismo está representando
la multiplicación de 5 por t observamos
que este punto no es el punto decimal
porque está arriba del punto decimal y
por lo tanto representa una
multiplicación entonces puedes escribir
5 puntos o 5 tm ambas son las respuestas
correctas y es la respuesta correcta
porque para obtener la distancia hay que
multiplicar a la velocidad
el tiempo en este caso por las horas que
ella tardó así que vamos a comprobar la
respuesta
y vamos a pasar al siguiente dice
hillary hizo 48 galletas de chispas de
chocolate y galletas de azúcar cuántas
galletas hizo hillary a en total
escribe tu respuesta como una expresión
bueno pues para obtener esta expresión
lo que vamos a hacer es tomarnos la
cantidad de galletas de chispas de
chocolate que ya hizo que sabemos que es
48 ya eso hay que aumentarle a eso hay
que sumarle la cantidad de galletas de
azúcar que ella hizo que nosotros
sabemos que es james es decir si nos
tomamos la suma de la cantidad de
galletas de chispas de chocolate que ya
hizo y de las galletas de azúcar que ya
hizo vamos a obtener las galletas en
total que hizo hillary muy bien
supongamos que ella hizo dos galletas de
azúcar
entonces tendríamos 48 más 250 y
podríamos decir que ella hizo 50
galletas en total no sé si ella hizo 100
galletas azúcar entonces en este caso yo
valdrá
y me quedaría 48 más ciento 148 galletas
que hizo hillary en total muy bien vamos
a comprobar la respuesta y vamos a hacer
un último problema bien ahora tenemos
este es al patín un total de 623
kilómetros entre días cada día para ti
no la misma distancia cuántos kilómetros
para ti no están cada día escribe tu
respuesta como una expresión bien pues
si cada día para ti no la misma
distancia y para ti no de días entonces
vamos a empezar con estos 600 23
kilómetros pero ahora lo que vamos a
hacer es dividirlos y para eso vamos a
usar este símbolo que tengo aquí este
símbolo que tengo aquí me va a dar la
división y me voy a tomar a 623 y lo voy
a dividir entre el número de días
sabemos que el patrón esos seiscientos
23 kilómetros
por lo tanto acá abajo voy a poner una
de y esto nos va a dar el número de
kilómetros que patinó cada día si el
patín o la misma cantidad de kilómetros
cada día que es justo lo que nos dice
así que vamos a comprobar la respuesta
y de lujo aquí voy a acabar el vídeo y
espero que todos estos ejemplos te hayan
dado un poco de práctica sobre cómo
resolver este tipo de problemas pero
para que obtengas más práctica te
encargo que tú resuelvas este tipo de
ejercicios nos vemos en el siguiente